triangle abc is a right triangle with ac
is equal to 7 bc is equal to 24 and a
right angle at c so let's just try to
draw that
let's draw that let's draw the right
angle maybe we'll have to use some
coordinates so let's draw the right
angle at the origin
so let's say that this is c right over
here
this is c let's see ac is equal to seven
so a will put over here this distance
over here is going to be seven and then
we have the hypotenuse of our triangle
and then this can be
b and this distance over here they tell
us that bc
is equal to 24.
all right now point m is the midpoint of
a b so point m is right over here let me
do that in a different color
point m is the midpoint
it's the midpoint of a b so this
distance is equal to that distance and d
is on the same side of a
b so d is on the same side of a b as c
so c is on this side on i guess you call
it the left or the bottom left hand side
of a
b
so that a d is equal to b d is equal to
15.
so d is going to be someplace over here
it's going to be equal distant between a
and b obviously all of the points equal
distant between a and b are going to sit
on a line that looks something like that
this is the midpoint of a b so d is
going to sit right over here and it's 15
away from both a and b
so it would look something like that
that distance over there is 15
and then this distance this distance
over here is also going to be 15.
given that the area of triangle cdm
so the area of triangle cdm this is d
so c
d
m is the triangle that they want to
think about given that the area of
triangle cdm may be expressed as m times
the square root of n over p where m n
and p are positive integers and m and p
are relatively prime so that just means
you can't simplify it and n is not
divisible by the square of any prime so
kind of n is
you've simplified the radical as much as
possible
find m plus n plus p so we essentially
need to find the area the area of this
green triangle of cdm over here and so
let's see what we can do to figure it
out so we could try some of the
coordinates for some of these points so
this point right over here a is going to
be its x value is going to be 7. i could
draw the coordinate just so you see what
i'm doing that could be the x-axis
and then this side is on the y-axis so
the coordinate for a would be 7 comma 0.
coordinate for c would be 0 0 and
coordinate for b would be 24
sorry would be 0 24
0 24. so the coordinate for m would just
be the average of b and a
so the coordinate for m the average of 0
and 7 is 7 halves
and the coordinate for
the y coordinate the average of 24 and 0
is 12.
that's fair enough now let's see what we
can figure out about the side so we know
this is a right triangle so our gut
reaction is always to use the
pythagorean theorem we know this side
and that side so if we wanted to figure
out a b we could just say that
we just know that 24 squared
plus 7 squared
is equal to
is equal to a b is equal to a b squared
and 24 squared is
576 plus 49 is equal to
a b squared and let's see 576 plus 49
if it was plus 50 it would get us to 5
20 it gives us a 626 but it's one less
than that so it's 625. so 625 is equal
to
a b
squared so a b is going to equal 25 so a
b
is equal to 25 so this distance this the
distance of this big hypotenuse here is
25 or
half of the distance this is going to be
25 over 2 from v to m from m to a is
also going to be 25 over 2.
now the other thing we know the other
thing we know
is that
m right over here
m right over here the triangle c m a is
an isosceles triangle how do we know
that well m if you look at its x
coordinate its x coordinate is directly
in between the x coordinates for c and a
seven halves it's the average this is
seven this is zero its m coordinate is
right over this directly above the
midpoint of this base over here so this
is going to be an isosceles triangle
symmetric you could flip the triangle
over so this length this length and this
seems useful because this is kind of the
base of the area that of the tr the base
of the triangle we care about we can
kind of view this as the base of cdm
this is also going to be 25 over 2
25 over 2. it's an isosceles triangle
this is going to be the same as that
because we're symmetric around this
right over here so see we know one side
of this triangle let's see if we could
figure out this side over here it seems
pretty straightforward this is going to
be a right triangle right over here
because this line
from d to m is going to be perpendicular
to a b
all of the points that are equidistant
between a and b are going to be on a
line that is perpendicular that is
perpendicular to a b
so this is going to be a right triangle
so we can figure out dm using the
pythagorean theorem again
we get 25 over 2 squared
25 over 2 squared plus dm squared
plus dm squared
plus dm squared is going to be equal to
15 squared is going to equal to the
hypotenuse of this triangle so it's
going to equal 225
and so what do we get we get
dm squared
dm
squared is equal to
225 minus 625 over four so let's put
this over four so 225 over four or 225
with four is the denominator is the same
thing as 900
900 over four and in the last video i
actually figured i mistakenly said 900
over 4 was 125 obviously boneheaded
mistake but the numbers show up again
here so 225 is obviously 900 over four
and then we're going to subtract from
that 625 over 4 minus 625
over 4 and this is equal to
see in our numerator let's see we have
900 minus 625 would be 300 minus 20 it's
going to be 200
275 over four and so dm is going to be
equal to the square root of this so it's
equal to the square root of 275 over 4.
275 is 25
times 11 because 25 times 12 would be
300. so 25 times 11
over 4 so this is going to be equal to 5
square roots of 11
over 2
so dm is 5 square roots of 11 over 2.
now if we could just figure out
so what we need to do here is figure out
the height of this triangle right over
here if we could figure out the height
of that triangle we're we're pretty much
done one half the base times the height
but we don't know you see we could
figure that if we know the law of
cosines we could do something over there
if we know the sine of this angle right
over here if we know the sine of that
angle the sine of that angle is going to
be this height over the side we just
figured out so if we could figure out
the sine of that angle then we'd be done
or we'll be very close to being done but
it's not any obvious way but one thing
we can do if you look at this bigger
triangle over here so let me highlight
it so if you look at triangle bmc let me
draw a triangle bmc
b well i'll just draw it on this drawing
right over here i don't want to get too
overloaded but triangle b
m
c right over here we know this side is
25 over 2. we know this side over here
is 25 over two we know this side over
here is 24
and we know this so what we want to do
is figure out the sign of this angle
right here the sine of theta of angle c
m d
now that's hard to do but what we can do
is use the law of cosines of theta plus
90. so let's let me let me redraw our
triangle so triangle bcm i could redraw
like this
i could redraw it's actually an
isosceles triangle so we have b
c
m
and what is this angle right over here
it's going to be our theta that we care
about plus 90 degrees so this angle
right here is theta
theta plus
90 degrees and this over here is 24 this
is 25 over 2 and this is 25 over 2. and
so using this we could use the law of
cosines to figure out to figure out what
theta actually is here
so let's do that we're going to use a
little bit of trig identities but law of
cosines so we get
the opposite to the angle squared so we
get 24 squared
24 squared is equal to 25 over 2 squared
25 over 2 squared plus 25 over 2 squared
plus 25 over 2 squared minus
2 times 25 over 2
times 25 over 2
times the cosine of this angle
times let me scroll over the cosine
of theta
theta plus
theta plus 90 degrees now you're saying
hey sal you know this has it in terms of
cosine of theta plus 90 degrees how can
we figure out the sine of theta that's
what we actually care about to figure
out the area of this triangle actually
to figure out the height of this
triangle and to do that you just have to
make the realization we know the trig
identity we know the trig identity that
the cosine of theta is equal i won't use
theta because i don't overload theta
cosine of x
is equal to sine
of 90 minus x
so the cosine of theta plus 90 degrees
is going to be equal to the sine of
let me put in parenthesis 90 minus
whatever's here 90 minus theta
minus 90
which is equal to the 90s cancel out
sine of negative theta and we know sine
of negative theta is equal to the
negative
sine of theta so this over here
simplifies to this is the negative sine
of theta so we could write the sine of
theta here
and then put the negative out here and
this becomes a positive so what does
this simplify to we have 24 squared
which is 576.
576 is equal to
let's see we have i'll just i won't skip
any steps here so we have 25 squared
plus 25 squared this is 2 times 25
this is 2
2 times 25 over 2
squared
squared plus
2 times this is 25 over 2 squared again
2 times 25 over 2 squared times sine of
theta now we just have to solve for sine
of theta so this is going to be equal to
well this is
is equal to
2 times 25 over 2 squared
i'm just factoring that out 1 plus sine
of theta
1 plus sine of theta or we can just
divide both sides of the equation by
this year actually let me just simplify
it this thing over here is 625 over 4
but then we're going to multiply that by
2 so this thing over here is 625
over 2. so let's divide both sides of
this by 625 over 2 and we get
times
times 2 over 625
just multiplying both sides by the
inverse is equal to when you multiply
both sides of the inner side this
actually cancels out is equal to
plus sine of theta
or sine of theta we just subtract 1 from
both sides we get sine of theta
is equal to 576 times two let's see 76
times two is 152
plus a thousand so it's 1152
over
625 that's that part there minus one but
instead of one let's say 625 over 625 so
minus
625 and this is equal to i'll have to do
a little math on the side so
1152 minus
you get a 12 there this becomes a four
12 minus five is seven four minus two is
two eleven minus six is five so this is
equal to five hundred and twenty seven
over six twenty five now you might not
realize it but we're in the home stretch
now let's let's draw let me draw this
cdm triangle the one that is really the
focus of the problem and let me draw it
a little bit differently
let me draw it
let me draw it slightly differently so
now we know some very interesting things
about cdm so this is c
this is d and this is m we know this
side over here we figured out is 5
halves square root 11. 5 over 2 times
the square root 11 that's the length of
dm
we also know that cm right over here is
25 over 2. we also know that sine of
theta here we also know that sine of
theta is equal to 527
over 625 that's what we just figured out
and we can use that to figure out the
height
the height of this triangle because we
know that sine is
is the opposite over the hypotenuse if
we draw a right triangle right here so
sine of theta
is
which is 527 over 625 is equal to the
opposite is equal to the height of this
triangle
is equal to the height of this triangle
over the hypotenuse over
5 over 2 square roots of 11. so we can
multiply both sides of this by 5 square
roots of 5 over 2 square roots 11
and we get
the height of the triangle is equal to
over
times
5 over 2
square root
of 11. and let's see we can divide 625
divided by 5 is
125 so you get a 1 here and you have a
over here so this is equal to
square roots 11
over 125 times 2 which is 200
250 that's the height now what's the
area of the triangle it's one half base
times height
area is equal to one half base
which is 25 over two
25 over 2 times the height
which we just figured out is
527 square roots of 11 over
250. let's see 25 divide the numerator
by 25 divide the denominator by 25 you
get a 10 there so this is equal to
square roots of 11 over 2 times 2 times
10 which is 40. so that's our area and
the whole problem they didn't want us to
find the area they want us to find m
plus n plus p
m plus n plus p so they want us to find
essentially 527 plus 11 plus 40.
plus 11
plus 40.
so 527 plus 11 is 5. let me make sure i
do this 538
and then plus 40 is
578 and we're done